ahora resolveremos un problema de
movimiento de proyectiles en dos
dimensiones un poquito más complicado en
este caso voy a lanzar mi proyectil
desde una plataforma más o menos así
este proyectil va a aterrizar en esta
plataforma que tiene una elevación
diferente de la plataforma en donde fue
lanzado el proyectil voy a lanzar el
proyectil desde un cañón que está aquí y
este cañón tiene un ángulo de 53 grados
y este proyectil va a salir del cañón va
a salir disparado así iba a salir
disparado de la boca del cañón con una
velocidad de 90 metros por segundo y
para conocer a qué altura fue lanzado
nuestro proyectil o va a ser lanzado
para darnos una idea más precisa vamos a
decir que desde la boca del cañón hasta
el suelo tenemos una altura de 25 metros
la elevación que tenemos aquí en esta
otra plataforma es de 9 metros así que
estamos lanzando este proyectil desde
una altura de 25 metros yo sé que en el
vídeo anterior
vamos a verlo brevemente aquí supusimos
que el lanzamiento se realizaba a nivel
del suelo es decir no tenía ninguna
elevación y el proyectil caía de vuelta
al suelo sin ninguna elevación también
en cambio
aquí no estamos lanzando con una altura
de 25 metros o desde una altura de 25
metros y comenzará a desacelerarse al
menos al menos en el componente vertical
tan pronto deje la boca del cañón y aquí
también suponemos que no va a caer en la
misma altura va a caer a una altura
diferente como vamos a analizar este
problema lo primero que queremos hacer
siempre que trabajemos con este tipo de
problemas es descomponer nuestro vector
velocidad en sus componentes horizontal
y vertical usaremos nuestro componente
vertical para determinar cuánto tiempo
esté al proyectil en el aire y después
usaremos eso junto con ese componente
horizontal para calcular qué tan lejos
llegó y nuevamente aquí vamos a suponer
que no tenemos ninguna resistencia al
aire y con base lo que vimos en el vídeo
anterior aunque aquí también voy a verlo
paso por paso lo que hicimos es primero
dibujar nuestro vector velocidad su
longitud es de 90 y el ángulo que va a
indicar la dirección de nuestro vector
velocidad el ángulo que forma este
vector con respecto a la horizontal es
de 53 grados
y ahora dibujemos el componente
horizontal que va a quedar más o menos
así y el componente vertical que estará
así y cuál va a ser la longitud de este
componente vertical bueno vemos que este
es el lado que está opuesto al ángulo y
sabemos de nuestra trigonometría básica
que el seno relaciona el lado opuesto y
la hipotenusa así que sabemos que el
seno de 53 grados es igual a este lado
que es la magnitud de nuestra velocidad
vertical o el componente vertical
de este vector y la longitud de nuestra
hipotenusa es de 90 si multiplicamos
ambos lados de esta ecuación por 90 nos
va a quedar que este componente vertical
o belle porque se encuentra en el eje de
leyes va a ser igual a 90
por el seno de 53 grados ahora si
queremos conocer este componente
horizontal bueno vemos que este lado
está adyacente al ángulo
así que usaremos el cose no recordemos
nuestro neumónico soca tohá que
significa coseno del ángulo es igual al
cateto adyacente entre la hipotenusa así
que el componente horizontal o en la
dirección x de nuestra velocidad que es
este cateto adyacente entre la
hipotenusa va a ser igual al coseno de
53 grados el coche no es el adyacente
entre la hipotenusa este componente
horizontal es el adyacente y esta es la
hipotenusa multiplicamos ambos lados por
90 y nos queda que nuestro componente
horizontal
x va a ser igual a 90 por coseno de 53
grados bueno ahora como vamos a
encontrar que tanto tiempo permanece
este objeto en el aire bueno para eso
usaremos nuestro componente vertical que
es esto que acabamos de calcular y ya
que aquí estamos trabajando con
diferentes elevaciones no podemos usar
nuestra fórmula simplificada como en el
vídeo anterior en el que decíamos que
con la misma velocidad de lanzamiento de
despegue iba a ser la misma velocidad de
aterrizaje solo que en dirección opuesta
es decir la misma magnitud de la
velocidad pero en dirección opuesta aquí
no podemos aplicar esto porque tenemos
diferentes elevaciones pero lo que sí
podemos hacer es usar la fórmula que
encontramos en el vídeo anterior esta
fórmula de acá en el que el
desplazamiento es igual a nuestra
velocidad inicial por el cambio en el
tiempo más la aceleración por el cambio
en el tiempo al cuadrado entre 2 voy a
copiar esto y pegarlo para tenerlo más a
la mano
aquí está aquí lo vamos a dejar y bueno
ya habíamos explicado qué es esto el
desplazamiento es igual a la velocidad
inicial por el cambio en el tiempo o el
tiempo que transcurre en el aire más la
aceleración que en este caso es nuestra
aceleración de la gravedad por el cambio
en el tiempo al cuadrado entre dos como
vamos a usar esta fórmula para encontrar
el tiempo en el aire
bueno verticalmente hablando cuál va a
ser nuestro desplazamiento iniciamos con
una altura de 25 metros y vamos a
terminar con una altura de 9 metros así
que mientras este objeto está en el aire
vamos a tener el desplazamiento más o
menos desde acá hacia abajo nuestro
desplazamiento va a ser de 16 metros que
es la diferencia entre 25 y 9 otra forma
de verlo es que nuestro desplazamiento
en la dirección de iu vertical
va a ser igual a menos 16 metros así que
podemos usar este desplazamiento y
sustituirlo en la fórmula que
encontramos en el vídeo anterior
voy a tener menos 16 no voy a poner las
unidades para no quedarme sin espacio
ahorita que escriba a todos los números
y esto va a ser igual a nuestra
velocidad inicial esto solo aplica a
nuestro componente vertical así que
recordemos que esto solo es con respecto
a la vertical o el componente vertical
esta cantidad es negativa porque nuestro
desplazamiento va a ser hacia abajo
recordemos que por nuestra convención
todas las cantidades negativas indican
la dirección hacia abajo y las positivas
indican la dirección hacia arriba al
menos cuando estamos hablando del
componente vertical y el componente
vertical de la velocidad
aquí lo encontramos nuestra belle es
igual al 90 por 0 de 53 así que esto es
igual 90 por el seno de 53 grados
x el cambio en el tiempo por el cambio
en el tiempo y lo que sigue es vamos a
sumar la aceleración por el cambio en el
tiempo al cuadrado entre 2 aquí la
aceleración es la ocasionada por la
fuerza de gravedad la aceleración va a
ser hacia abajo así que aquí de entrada
vamos a tener un signo negativo
corresponde menos la aceleración de la
gravedad es 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado hacia abajo entre 2 nos da 4.9
por el cambio en el tiempo al cuadrado
vamos a poner aquí esto para que quede
más claro cómo resolvemos algo así aquí
no podemos factorizar del tate y
resolverlo pero pueden reconocer aquí
que tenemos una ecuación cuadrática y
recordamos que la forma de resolver
ecuaciones cuadráticas es primero tener
todos los términos de un lado de la
ecuación y después factorizar lo o lo
que parece que vamos a usar aquí es usar
la fórmula cuadrática
que ya demostramos en otro vídeo aquí
vamos a obtener dos soluciones una de
ellas va a ser con un valor negativo
como si regresáramos en el tiempo lo
cual pues no es posible ese no nos
interesa lo que nos interesa es el
tiempo transcurrido hasta que cayó el
proyecto ir al suelo
bueno aquí lo que queremos hacer es
dejar todos los términos de un solo lado
de la ecuación para eso vamos a sumar 16
en ambos lados de esta ecuación
y al sumarlos nos va a quedar 0 de este
lado menos 16 más 16 es igual a 0 y esto
va a ser igual y todo esto lo voy a
escribir de la manera tradicional en
donde el término con la mayor potencia
va primero después el siguiente hasta
que lleguemos a la constante en este
caso es
- 4.9 por el cambio en el tiempo al
cuadrado
más 90 por el seno de 53 grados por
delta t más lo que sumamos
6 todo esto es igual a 0 y esta es una
ecuación cuadrática así que podemos
encontrar sus raíces y estas raíces van
a estar en términos de delta t
y ahora usaremos la ecuación cuadrática
y ahora usaremos nuestra fórmula
cuadrática de estate
es igual y si esto no les parece para
nada familiar les recomiendo que vean
nuestros vídeos en la lista de álgebra
acerca de la fórmula cuadrática si no
saben de dónde sale ahí se lo
demostramos esto va a ser igual a menos
b b en este caso este término que
multiplican a delta t el coeficiente de
delta t menos b entonces es menos 90
seno de 53 grados y mejor escribo la
fórmula cuadrática por aquí arriba para
aquellos de ustedes que no la recuerden
exactamente tenemos que es a por x
cuadrada más b por x más e igual a cero
este es el formato de nuestra ecuación
cuadrática la solución a las raíces de
esta ecuación nos vamos a encontrar
aplicando la fórmula menos b más menos
raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada
-4 hace la raíz cuadrada de esto
todo esto dividido entre 2
estos serán los valores de x que
satisfacen a esta ecuación y eso es lo
que estamos haciendo aquí abajo este es
mi valor de b correspondiente esta
ecuación y aquí como va menos b es menos
90 seno de 53 grados más menos y aquí
bueno en este caso nosotros vamos a
estar interesados solo en la raíz
positiva pero vamos a escribir ambas
aquí para mantener la congruencia con
esta fórmula raíz cuadrada
de be cuadrada nuestra ve cuadrada es
esta misma 90 por seno de 53 grados al
cuadrado y me estoy quedando sin espacio
vamos a hacer un poquito más de espacio
aquí menos 4 lo ponemos aquí 4 x a éste
es a por 4 menos 4.9 por c que es este
de aquí por 16 y vamos a extender aquí
nuestra raíz todo esto dividido entre
dos por a
es menos 4.9 esto por 2 nos da menos 9.8
y ahora podemos sacar nuestra
calculadora para encontrar el cambio en
el tiempo y sólo nos va a interesar la
versión positiva de esto les quedara
ustedes de tarea encontrar la raíz
negativa encontrar un valor negativo
para el cambio en el tiempo lo cual
realmente no tiene sentido ya que la
podemos regresar en el tiempo así que
sacamos la calculadora
y nos queda vamos a hacer esto con mucho
cuidado menos 90 por seno de 53 grados
más recordamos que aquí estamos haciendo
la versión positiva más la raíz cuadrada
de 90 por seno de 53 grados al cuadrado
estos dos signos negativos se cancelan
por lo que queda más 4 por 4.9 por 16
aquí cerramos nuestra raíz y eso me va a
dar el numerador de aquí y el numerador
es 2.14 de 93 y vamos a dividir esto
entre menos 9.8 y que queden aquí me
equivoqué yo les había dicho que si
tomábamos la parte positiva de este raíz
obtendríamos el cambio en el tiempo
positivo pero al hacer esta operación
como tenemos en el denominador un signo
negativo nos va a quedar un cambio en el
tiempo negativo y es lo que no nos
interesa entonces nos va a interesar el
tiempo en donde aquí arriba tengamos un
signo negativo vamos a reescribir de
nuevo esto en la calculadora
y vamos ahora a usar el valor negativo
regresemos un poco aquí y cambiamos este
signo de más a menos así que aquí me
interese la revista negativa porque me
interesa un tiempo positivo y ahora mi
numerador es un número negativo menos
145 punto 9 y ahora sí teniendo el
numerador negativo como tenemos un
denominador negativo ambos se van a
cancelar y nos va a quedar un resultado
positivo
ahora si dividimos esto entre menos 9.8
y esto nos va a dar 14.88 81 y vamos a
redondear lo a 14.89 segundos así que
nuestro cambio en el tiempo
la versión positiva de esas posibles
soluciones es 14.89 segundos así que mi
comentario anterior de que nos
interesaba aquí la raíz positiva era
erróneo bien el signo del denominador
realmente la que nos interesaba es la
raíz negativa ya que solamente cuando
tenemos nuestro numerador negativo
tendremos toda nuestra expresión
positiva así que obtenemos ésta
de 14.89 segundos el tiempo que el
proyectil permaneció en el aire desde
aquí hasta acá es de 14.89 segundos para
encontrar el desplazamiento total
tendremos que multiplicar este cambio en
el tiempo por la magnitud de nuestro
componente horizontal de la velocidad y
de hecho ya encontramos este valor del
componente horizontal de nuestra
velocidad así que para encontrar el
desplazamiento total realizado desde
nuestro lanzamiento hasta quedar el
proyectil de nuevo en el suelo es hacer
esta multiplicación sacamos nuestra
calculadora y este tiempo lo vamos a
multiplicar por este valor de aquí un 90
por coseno de 53 grados y eso nos da 800
6.39 metros si redondeamos podemos decir
que este desplazamiento de aquí es de
800 6 metros